[Music]
Jefferson airplane's music provided the
soundtrack to the summer of love the
band's psychedelic San Francisco sound
forged in part by founding member Marty
ballon ballon died Thursday at the age
of 76 after Jefferson Airplane took off
in 1967 the band took center stage at
the era's biggest events including the
San Francisco human bein the Monterey
Pop Festival Altamont
and of course Woodstock a little over a
year later balon left the band but was
lured back when some of the members
formed Jefferson Starship
[Music]
the song miracles which balan rope
climbed all the way to number three on
the charts Balan would leave the band
again
but participated in reunion tours over
the decades to come when Jefferson
Airplane was inducted into the Rock and
Roll Hall of Fame in 1996 Balon thanked
the city that gave the band it starts
[Applause]
thank you very much Jefferson Starship
was come more commercially successful I
think but Jefferson Airplane was a
really influential band I mean that
sound still means a lot
it wasn't my generation but they spoke
for a generation welcome we were kind of
the breakthrough acted in the 60s in San
Francisco even before Janis Joplin and
those it was airplane that emerged first